[Music]
in blame game news submitted by JK come
to Vietnam I'll be tomorrow
a woman who failed a random drug test
blames it on sweaty sex with a coke user
oh so many times
really athletes yeah so there was this
one girl what she's a weightlifter right
she got drug tested she she disciplined
for steroids she goes I never took them
I was giving my boyfriend a [ __ ]
he's the one that takes up and I
swallowed his [ __ ] that's not how I work
take that take that clip of David and
just replay it and I swallowed his
compel his company so so she basically
threw her boyfriend under the bus to get
out of it yeah
weed oh that's not me that's just my
family they grow it in the backyard and
make a lot of money off of it and I
sucked my brother off last night if it's
that important to you just my name but I
need this job look at my black shirts
think I stayed on look I failed a drug
test one and I don't do drugs
I felt the drug test because of them I
had sushi the night before and [ __ ]
the poppy seeds yeah roll like she was a
dirty night and that's a real thing yeah
it's a real oh really it was supposed to
be my first yeah
wasn't my first job ever at Target you
know and I drug test you at Target are
you yeah you wouldn't think that when
you go they probably don't want any meth
heads to like collect the shopping carts
and stuff even though they'd be the best
at it
hello organized
but also Google says you're lying and
that's not possible no that's not true I
used two googly googly nurse just nurse
she's a nurse from Melbourne machine
nurse she's a nurse profession nurse
I think nurse I think of a lady in a
porno partition I gotta remember that
they are they wearing a scrub and stuff
like that yeah yeah I got it that's not
the white cap with the cross and the
[ __ ] Shelley the Coco anybody with
eyebrows like that loves cocaine yeah so
Tara she that's why I keep repeating
that she's a nurse because she's only
making this ridiculous claim oh yeah
what was the claim again I'm sorry she
said poppy seeds are CG she [ __ ] a
coke addict which gave her negative test
results for IV positive results whether
it was sweaty sex so here there was this
pathologist chemical pathologist that
was like okay no way that can happen
unless you swallowed 17 ounces of his
semen then maybe that that is possible
that this little this is 16.9 ounces
that's possible so this is how much
seeming yet that that whole bottle is 16
ounces
yes teen point nine hole that's more
than a [ __ ] party yeah but what if
she had a [ __ ] boy
admit the blue-collar everyone has to
have coq10 I am a hundred percent sure
she is a nurse she works very long hours
she needs a little pick-me-up so she
does little but any nurse that tries to
fool the system any nurse that tries to
fool the system by saying oh I sucked on
his [ __ ] and he's a coke addict like
that's [ __ ] stupid she should just be
fired because she's dumb like she was
saying that she had sex with this man
who claims that she didn't know that he
used cocaine and so she had unprotected
sex with this guy in the morning and
then after she didn't take a shower she
didn't use a rush Cucina she did
household chores she went out to I don't
know so why'd you call her kitchen
earlier though why did you call her a
car showers
[Laughter]
yeah so she ended up going to work at
2:00 p.m. and that's when she got this
random testing done lazy she works at -
good [ __ ] yeah and then but this lady or
this nurse she already has a history of
drug use monitoring her or like randomly
testing her but she had been doing good
for some time with nothing coming back
positive but this time teacher yeah
which I'm thinking while there's just
fire her if she's still using drugs
she's probably killing the [ __ ] game
[ __ ] on cocaine like getting that
[ __ ] not okay that was my answer the
question she's an excellent nurse she
could work at my hospital but what hurt
all the [ __ ] I hope you watch because
what if it gets out of hand you know
what an addiction what she means the
coke to do long hours like house exactly
you got pink killers yeah he does paint
you know what people come and go
unfortunately sometimes people that live
the fast life also and the fast life
real fast
so she's gonna work real hard and good
for a couple of years but then
unfortunately i'ma have to give her the
boot but while she can work really hard
I'm a keeper for those two years wait
what
I get it as much as she aspires he knew
she was gonna expire in two years
exactly but he said but then prior to
that he also said she could do whatever
she wants until two years
she's a bullet train and she's not an
Amtrak so I'm down she tested her hair
before and they found methamphetamine oh
[ __ ] watch amphetamine and non
prescribed sedative Szold PBM and geez
[ __ ] hair rats rot like that that's
crazy she don't [ __ ] shower oh yeah
just spilled in her hair
yeah you should shower after sex yeah
you guys are so mean this she's a
lifesaver dude and it's Lucia she's
[ __ ] wait she's it's 4:00 a.m. she's
she's wide awake at 4:00 a.m. there's
someone with bullet wounds and kangaroo
bites and [ __ ] and she's like digging
she's yeah she's like helping people
I've never heard of a kangaroo my victim
ever in my life they're vicious creature
[ __ ] nobodies like punching kick
though I've never seen they go pop out
you know [ __ ] kangaroo bites
whatever's happening she's there to help
she's doing that with the [ __ ] itchy
vagina too and she just [ __ ] a
crackhead so like she's busy being a
Mario give her a break dude busy being a
nobody
I know [ __ ] armadillo [ __ ] telling
me if you're in the hospital in
Australia town you just got an emergency
[ __ ] koalas [ __ ] here under
Wolverine scratch I know it's a [ __ ]
a sloth sloth by job if you get bit by a
[Laughter]
even after they bite you you have to
come
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys are so insensitive she's a hard
worker she's a hard heart don't forget
that if she won't take a shower I'd be
okay with it yeah why she's so nasty
yeah but she's mine she took a shower
that's sure to be like no that's why I
told me she showered she snorted that
coke off that dick then she stuck there
yeah well maybe the dude was doing coke
off her [ __ ] and the coke went in her
[ __ ] oh and her boss was a freak and
he tested her ass like they put the
thermometer in debajo they put the drug
tester in Abajo 27:38 just for the
picture alone she's [ __ ] 83 but she
looks like she's 19 damn I need on the
coat you know what's crazy
you know how like so like cocaine is
like a really popular drug and I was I
was surprised too like it's like it's
low-key it has like it's kind of like a
cocaine Renaissance right now I know
even like a renaissance in hard yo me
stop well that's Fame you know why is
because you guys don't really go out
anymore - like when you go out to any
kind of like bar in k-town these
[ __ ] are doing inside the
bathroom it's crazy it's like Hollywood
it's like Hollywood [ __ ] I'm saying so I
was talking to this girl I knew tiny
girl like um super cute super like
innocent looking when I wasn't looking
but he was like I knew her and I was
like I think you know it's crazy it's
crazy how cocaine is like so popular now
and she's like
cuz it's awesome oh [ __ ] my bad so
nobody's here there's gonna be a huge
crackdown soon
nobody's tried it I've tried it I tried
it in high school I smoked crack but I
never [ __ ] crazy
you know why cuz I like that it's like
five ten bucks and [ __ ] and you battle
[ __ ] you just smoke that with your
friends like I thought that was like
crazy [ __ ] what is it like now it's like
the kings crack uh it was just so I was
fifteen when I did it yeah and then you
just feel like you're just [ __ ]
invincible you're just like let's
[ __ ] do this
remember crack only lasts on one minute
and your life every single cell in my
body is getting a massage right now
oh wait that's it I need another one
that's why it's so addictive that's
great it's like one [ __ ] minute
you're just someone asked you a question
you're like you're like that's it I need
another one where's my school don't do
crack guys it's [ __ ] crazy and just
chilling at the stoplight about Scott
Street and there's a SUV full of white
boys high school white boys see my young
white was and they roll by and they're
like what the [ __ ] is up [ __ ] bag of
cocaine I was like oh my hey guys would
you think of that video I know you loved
it so make sure to hit that like button
to watch more videos check it out up
here